Professor Robert
Shiller: What I want to talk
about today is about places
where stocks are exchanged--or
bonds or other securities.
It's another huge industry.
I would say it's part of our
information technology--our
information network.
What we have to do is find a
national or international price
for a security.
The problem is that when
securities are traded without a
central market,
different people will be
getting different prices for the
same thing.
We have what's called--or maybe
the term--what markets do for us
is--the important term is "price
discovery."
That means that there is a
market price that an asset would
have if everybody in the whole
world were free to buy and sell
the asset on the same market and
at the same time.
But if you don't have an
organized exchange,
which is open and available to
everybody without a lot of cost,
then you don't have effective
price discovery and that means
that nobody knows what the asset
is worth in the whole market.
We take price discovery for
granted but we have to realize
that there's a technology that
brought us that and it's the
technology that we want to
emphasize that has been
improving over the years;
it's not static.
I wanted to start by just
defining some important terms
regarding exchange of
securities.
One important term is
"broker"--and I'll put it over
here--another one is "dealer."
Those are the two kinds of
people who trade securities.
It's important to keep the
concept, so one thing that's
used to describe is to start
with the letters
BOAC--that sounds likes
it's British Overseas Airways
Corporation,
but that's not what I mean.
This is a mnemonic to remember
broker.
It says brokers act on
Behalf or for
Others as an Agent
for which they earn a
Commission.
A broker goes between two
people and the two people trade
with each other.
The broker makes it happen and
the broker receives a fee called
a commission for bringing these
people together so that they
could find each and make the
deal--make the trade.
For dealer, we have a
different--it's DHPM.
A Dealer acts for
Herself or Himself
as a Principal for a
Markup;
that's the fundamental
difference.
In contrast to a broker,
the dealer actually buys and
sells himself or herself and
that means the dealer has an
inventory of whatever it is
that--so that the dealer has
something to sell.
If you go to a dealer and buy a
security, you're buying it from
the dealer out of the dealer's
inventory.
If you sell through a dealer,
you sell to the dealer.
There's a fundamental diff--the
markup is the difference between
the price that the dealer buys
and sells at;
so, you see that there's a
fundamental difference.
Now, securities law says that
you can never function as both a
broker and a dealer in the same
transaction.
You've got to be one or the
other.
The same person can do both.
You can be both a broker and a
dealer, but not in the same
transaction.
We also have the term in
finance "broker-dealer" and
that's called BD.
A BD is a firm that hires--that
employs brokers and dealers.
The fact that they hyphenate
them doesn't mean that any one
transaction involves both
brokering and dealing.
You can see the difference in
ordinary life.
When you buy and sell a house,
your real estate agent is a
broker.
The real estate agent usually
does not buy the house from you
if you're selling your house.
Or if you call up a real estate
agent and say,
"I want to sell my house," the
agent doesn't say,
"okay I'll buy it;"
so, that person is operating as
a broker.
However, if you go to an
antique shop and say you want to
buy a chest of drawers or a
dining room table,
you'll be dealing with a
dealer.
I guess there are fundamental
reasons in why it works out well
in one and why it tends to break
down differently for the
different--why is it that we
have dealers for antiques and
brokers for homes?
Well, I think it has something
to do with--can you tell me,
why do we do it that way?
I was thinking it has something
to do with the information cost
of--since buying a house is such
a big decision and you've got to
go looking at the houses anyway.
Somehow, antiques--you wouldn't
have an antique broker would
you?
I guess you could.
People could have antiques for
sale in their homes and the
antique broker would take you
around on a tour.
I wonder if that was my
Blackberry.
I am so wired here.
Yes, I think it was my
Blackberry.
The concept of a BD is that it
is something regulated,
once again by the Securities
and Exchange Commission;
that means any BD must register
with the SEC.
In that sense,
we have a sort of licensing for
BDs.
BDs in turn are responsible for
their employees,
who are acting as brokers and
dealers, and the employees will
have to be appropriately
licensed.
What BDs do is,
according to our securities
law, they would manage their
employees exams through
FINRA--now, I mentioned that
before.
That's the successor to
National Association of
Securities Dealers;
that has exams for brokers and
dealers.
What it is--a BD is a company
that hires people and they
become licensed as brokers or
dealers through their own BD
using FINRA,
so that's the organization
method that we have.
The reason why we have it this
way is that there are so many
instances of bad behavior among
brokers and dealers that have to
be handled.
This goes back to a basic theme
of this course that human nature
is imperfect and while economics
theory tries to describe people
as honest and following the
rules,
there are so many opportunities
for bad behavior that have to be
corrected.
I've taken the licensing exams
for FINRA because I wanted,
myself, to do creating of
securities.
I think it's actually a very
good program they have and they
have continuing education that
brokers and dealers have to
take.
One thing that they do in the
continuing education--I was
impressed with what they've come
up with--they have actors and
actresses portraying situations
that brokers and dealers will
come up with--will encounter
that are not quite ethical.
I remember there was a scene
where a woman comes up to the
broker and there's a document
that--she has a joint account
with her husband and there's a
document that requires both
their signatures.
The broker hands it to her and
she signs and then he says,
okay can you get your husband
to sign it?
She says, oh he already did,
look--right in front of the
broker and then they show the BD
backing down--this is in the
skit that I saw--and accepting,
okay.
She said, I'm sure it's all
right with him;
so he says, all right.
The skit goes on and shows how
much trouble he got into for
accepting.
Then, the husband shows up the
next day and they're getting a
divorce and he's furious and he
[the broker]
tries to cover it up by
pretending he didn't know.
She then comes back and admits
that he [the broker]
just told me it was all right
that my husband--I could sign
for my husband.
There are all kinds of moral
issues that arise and I think
that the system works as well as
it does because we have
institutions.
We recognize that there's a
tendency for all kinds of bad
behavior.
My own experience with FINRA
was increased confidence in our
BDs.
I think that we have a good
system--that there's going to be
a lot of temptation for bad
behavior.
We have a pretty good system in
this country for educating
people not to do that.
We also actually go after BDs
who do things that are seemingly
innocent.
For example,
churning--I mentioned this
before.
Churning is overtrading a
customer's account.
It's not obvious to uninformed
investors that it isn't a good
idea to trade stocks every other
day, but it's obvious to anyone
in the field.
If you're trading stocks that
frequently, there's just no way
that you could make money.
There's nobody who can get a
50% return on stocks with
reliability.
We know that David Swensen--we
mentioned him before--has got
18%, but he's the star and
you're not going to do that
well, realistically.
If you're churning--if you're
paying more then 18% in
commissions every year,
you just don't have a chance.
A broker could try to hide
behind some kind of
façade and say,
well but I think I can earn
that.
But fortunately,
we have good enough regulatory
agencies to stop that,
so right now,
brokers who churn their
portfolios will be caught by
market surveillance and they
will be thrown out of the
profession.
It's actually--you can be
disbarred--prevented from
trading for life.
That's the kind of regulations
we have.
I think it's a very--the world
is more ambiguous and faces more
moral dilemmas than you would
imagine.
You have to get out into the
business world and start seeing
how often they come up.
It's kind of remarkable that we
have a system that handles these
dilemmas as well as we do.
You see a lot of anger now,
for example with the subprime
crisis, and people who
supposedly or allegedly behave
very badly.
Certainly some of them did
behave badly,
but we have a system that,
I think, has developed over
many years that works pretty
well.
Now these are--so,
brokers and dealers are people
who work with the exchanges,
but I want to go on to talk
about the exchanges themselves
on which these people trade.
This is, unfortunately,
a difficult topic to keep up
with because the exchanges are
changing every year.
I think a big impetus for
change is the advance of
information technology.
I might say also,
financial technology.
This is a world in rapid change;
it's not fixed at all.
I wanted to just talk about
different kinds of exchanges
that we have.
Traditionally,
we say there are--in the U.S.,
there are four markets.
One of them is called the first
market and this is traditional
and that is the New York Stock
Exchange.
I'm going to come back--it's
now called NYSE-Euronext,
but let's just be traditional
for the moment.
New York Stock Exchange is the
old original stock market and
the dominant one,
so we call that the first
market.
Then there's the second market
and that is NASDAQ and that
stands for National Association
of Securities Dealers Automatic
Quotation System;
that was the first electronic
exchange.
It was founded--the New York
Stock Exchange was founded in
1792, NASDAQ was founded in
1971--very different tradition
between the two.
I should say,
the second market--I have to
add that--is the NASDAQ National
Market because NASDAQ is divided
into two parts;
there's the national market.
The third market,
so called third market,
is NASDAQ small-cap;
small-cap means companies whose
capitalization is low.
Capitalization,
remember, is the price per
share times the number of
shares, so it's the value of the
whole company.
The small caps are treated
separately on NASDAQ.
Then, there's the fourth market
and that's beyond the exchanges
itself.
This is--it's large
institutions trading amongst
themselves;
it does happen.
There's no law saying you have
to go through an exchange.
You can just buy and sell
whatever.
Especially if it's a very large
transaction it can happen that,
as part of some deal,
institutions will trade shares
and they don't have to go
through the market.
We really think that these are
the most important markets.
Let me--incidentally,
these are not the first stock
exchanges.
The United States did not
invent the stock exchange.
I think maybe I mentioned this
before, but Ulrike Malmondier,
who is a professor at Stanford,
has researched the Ancient
Roman stock exchange and claims
to have identified--I think I
said this before--but has
claimed to identify where in the
Roman forum the Roman
stockbrokers worked and it was
out of a certain temple.
You can find the location when
you visit Rome now.
I think it's in ruins,
but you can find where they
traded stocks;
it was never very big.
Then, some people in Anthrop
had the first modern stock
exchange--I don't know,
like many centuries ago.
Amsterdam was an early--London
was an early stock exchange.
So, we came kind of late in the
United States to stock
exchanges--1792 is kind of late
in the world history.
However, I think that the U.S.
actually features somewhat
prominently in the history of
stock exchanges because there
was a New York Securities
Law--1811--which became a model
for securities law and which
made the stock exchange in New
York especially important.
The 1811 Securities Law in New
York established two important
principles.
The first one was that anybody
can set up a corporation and
have it traded on the stock
exchange.
Anybody who satisfies some
criteria specified by the
securities regulator,
but the criteria did not
involve the state legislature
convening and giving you
permission;
it was automatic.
Didn't matter who you were;
they would do anybody,
but of course there were
restrictions.
The company may have had
certain capital requirements and
the like, but it was democratic.
Until then, it used to be that
in many countries companies
would require an act of
parliament to be found or the
king would have to sign
something.
Now, it was very clear that it
was democratic.
The other thing that the New
York Securities Law of 1811 did
was make it law that limited
liability was always the
standard.
That is that--limited liability
means that you,
as a stock market investor,
can never be sued for the
misdoings of the company you
invested in.
This was a very fundamental
step in securities law because
before 1811, while there was
some limited liability--the idea
was already out there and some
companies put limited liability
clauses in their charters--it
was never so clear as in New
York.
So, you didn't want to trade
and buy a few shares on some
exchange because you had the
possibility of getting hit for
that;
they could come after you.
With the New York Securities
Law of 1811, the New York Stock
Exchange began to really prosper
because then it became something
that anybody in the world could
come in and buy a share there
and have no worries--except,
you could only lose your money
that you put in,
nothing more.
That turned out to be a very
important innovation,
which came in the U.S.,
and accounts,
I think, for the importance of
New York in finance.
It was copied later in the
nineteenth century all over
Europe--this kind of securities
law--but it took a long time.
The New York Stock Exchange was
founded in 1792,
outdoors under a buttonwood
tree.
I've always wondered,
what was a buttonwood tree.
I guess some stock exchanges
occurred in coffee houses.
People used to like coffee,
just as they do now,
and that's a good place to
trade stocks.
You would be at Starbuck's or
something in London
probably--the equivalent of
Starbuck's--and it would be a
natural place to trade stocks.
Actually, the New York Stock
Exchange was founded under a
buttonwood tree.
I looked it up,
a buttonwood tree is just a
sycamore or American plain tree
and we have them--I was
wondering--we have them around
here;
they're just outside somewhere.
I don't know why they call them
buttonwoods;
maybe they made buttons out of
them--of the wood.
The system has gone on now for
well over two hundred years but
it's changing because of our
technology.
It's one of the themes of my
book, New Financial
Order, as to how much
technology has advanced our
financial markets and
institutions.
There was some--if you look at
the number of stocks traded on
the London Stock Exchange,
say, around 1800,
it was just a handful;
it was just not very big or not
very important.
But, it was certain kinds of
information technology that
really made stock exchanges take
off.
I'd like to just mention a few
of them.
One was--we were living in a
very primitive world in 1800.
People were actually using
feather pens--that's what you
would use at that time;
also, paper was very expensive
in 1800.
If you bought a newspaper,
if you look at newspapers from
1800, there would be a single
sheet, typically,
that folded in half--of paper.
Why was that?
Well, it's because paper was so
expensive, because in 1800 paper
had to be made out of scraps of
cloth;
they didn't have wood pulp
paper and they didn't have--it
had to be made by hand.
You'd have people washing the
fabric and then laying it on a
screen--all by hand--and then
rolling it;
so, it was too expensive.
We got--in the nineteenth
century, we got cheap paper and
then we got--I mention that I
think it's important for--we got
carbon paper;
this came in the nineteenth
century, although there were
some maybe primitive versions.
It allowed you to make copies.
The typewriter--that came in in
the late nineteenth century,
so you could make records much
more accurately with--and make
copies and it's important to
make copies so that they're
backed up.
We had printed forms,
although those actually go back
to the--in Holland,
I think, we traced them back to
maybe the 1700s.
The idea is having a document
with spaces to fill in numbers
and then you put it in the
typewriter;
you've got printed up multiple
copies of this with carbon paper
between them.
You type--it's very accurate;
it makes it possible to do
business.
We invented filing cabinets in
the 1890s;
that's comparatively
recently--it's kind of amazing.
Filing cabinets--we have the
drawers that come out and you
put file folders in;
it wasn't until the 1890s that
that came in.
Before that you would take
documents and tie them up with
ribbons and put them on
bookshelves.
Well, there may have been other
systems as well,
but we didn't have the modern
filing cabinet.
The really important thing was
electronic technology.
We had the telegraph,
which came in by Samuel Morse
in--when was that?
1840s?
I think I might have it.
Samuel Morse graduated from
Yale University in 1810 and he
patented the telegraph in 1837;
so it was 1837.
I'll mention--there's also a
college here.
Are you, anyone from Morse
College?
Yes?
Only one, nobody else from
Morse?
There's a good number.
He did something very important.
Incidentally,
he lived--his house is 58
Trumbull, which is three blocks
from here and if you want to,
you can walk over there and see
Morse's house.
He used to have inventions
parked out on his front lawn,
but they're not there anymore;
they've taken them in.
This was a very important
invention because electronic
communication instantly--or at
the speed of light
essentially--is what now
underpins our exchange.
The next thing that happened,
and that's a little bit later
in the technology,
was the ticker machine.
It's not entirely clear who
invented it but--because there
are various versions--but
apparently it was invented by
Thomas Edison.
This was--he was--this was his
first invention.
You've heard of many inventions
from Thomas Edison.
Quite remarkable that his first
invention was in the area of
finance and that was in 1867.
How old do you think he was
when he invented the ticker
machine?
He was twenty-three;
so that's just a--those of you
who are thinking of your
careers, some people get started
at a good, young age.
You probably don't even know
what a ticker machine is.
Do you know what I'm talking
about, a ticker machine?
Some of you do anyway.
What it was was like a computer
printer.
I mean.
he was just like way ahead of
his time.
We have these printers--you
have one in your room or
somewhere--that when electronic
signals come to it,
it prints out on the paper;
well, he invented one in 1867.
What it did--remember the
telegraph machine that Morse
invented was--it required humans
on both ends.
One person would be tapping on
the Morse Code on one end and
there would be another person
listening on the other end who
would transcribe it by hand.
So, Edison thought,
well there's no reason why it
shouldn't be done mechanically
at the receiving end,
so he invented a sort of
automatic typewriter that
printed out.
The initial application of it
was to stocks because that
was--that's the kind of
information people needed
continually on a big basis.
He invented this printer and
it's a little different from
modern--we have a standard paper
size now,
which is 8.5" x 11",
but he didn't want to use all
that.
Remember, paper was more
expensive then and he didn't
need to get a lot,
so he changed the shape of it.
So, the paper,
instead of being that wide,
was like that wide because all
he had to put was symbols for
stocks--abbreviations for their
names--and then the price at
which it traded.
He wanted to get a lot of these
in rapid succession out,
so he didn't need a wide width.
It's all very logical.
It was basically a computer
printer with a narrow width.
I forgot to bring it today;
I should have.
I was telling someone at the
New York Stock Exchange that I
was telling my students about
the ticker machine and students
didn't--my students didn't seem
to know anything about it.
Then he sent me as a gift a
ticker tape;
it was just a roll of paper
tape.
They were using ticker tapes at
the New York Stock Exchange
until 1964, I think it was,
and he said,
well we still have some in the
attic and he gave me a roll.
Maybe I'll try to bring it.
This is just,
maybe, a curious history about
communications.
Do you know what a ticker tape
parade is?
Some of you--these ticker
machines used to be printing out
stock prices constantly,
so this tape was just
constantly running and it would
pile up in these huge wads of
paper tape.
They had to always dispose of
it at the brokerages because all
this paper tape had to be thrown
away and it was a disposal
problem.
Whenever there was a parade
down Wall Street,
people would--they would use
this ticker tape like confetti
and they would tear it up into
shorter lengths and they would
toss it out the windows and so
you'd see all this paper tape
coming down.
We still--this is all obsolete
now, but in a sense it is
electronic communication
technology that--I guess we're
still wasting a lot of paper;
we just changed the width,
so we don't call it tape
anymore.
We call it printer paper or
something like that,
so it's not exactly the same.
The idea that we should have
one market--when we have ticker
tape machines--we still use the
word ticker symbol for the short
abbreviation of a stock,
so every stock has an
abbreviated name.
We don't need abbreviations
anymore because our printers are
much more effective,
but we still have them.
That's the official--the ticker
symbol is the official name for
a stock or other security that's
traded on an exchange.
When you have electronic
communication,
it should create a national
market that is--where everyone
is getting the same price.
However, it doesn't necessarily
work automatically.
In 1975, people made a number
of complaints to our lawmakers
in Washington that,
in fact, while we have ticker
machines and we have a lot
of--well actually,
they were already gone by
‘75, but there were a lot
of electronic communications.
But, some people were not
always getting the same price.
Someone would say,
I placed my order in the
Philadelphia Stock Exchange and
I got a bad price.
I realized later I could have
traded at some other
exchange--nobody told me--at the
same time.
So, Congress created--it was
The Securities Act of
1975--wanted to create a
national market system.
So, Congress mandated that
securities brokers set up some
kind of electronic system that
would allow people to trade on
whichever exchange has the best
price.
It was sort of a challenge to
the monopoly of the New York
Stock Exchange because your
broker--if you place an order
with your broker this--we would
have a new electronic system.
The broker would look over all
the different exchanges and see
which one had the best price;
that's what you want as a
customer.
It was implemented with
something called the
ITS--Intermarket Trading
System--which allows a broker to
look over all the exchanges to
find the best price.
That was set up with computers
in 19--or in the early
'70s--1975 or shortly after
1975.
It's been in place ever since;
however, because it was
mandated by Congress,
the computer system was up to
date and modern in the early
'70s or late '70s,
but it hasn't kept up and it's
considered slow,
as a sort of dinosaur,
and people want to avoid
trading in it.
In 2006, all the major
exchanges proposed that we
replace the ITS with something
called NMS linkage,
which is just a more modern
version of the computer
technology, but I haven't heard
anything about it being
implemented.
Again, since I don't
trade--maybe some of you know
what's happened with NMS linkage
system.
Let me put this--NMS linkage
was proposed,
but you see what's happening.
[The NMS Linkage plan was
activated and replaced the ITS
in June 2007]
When the government tries to
mandate a linking of exchanges,
that's not the same thing as
having a market impetus for
linking of exchanges,
so what's actually happened is
really ignoring the national
market system.
Computer technology has
advanced so rapidly it starts to
create opportunities for people
to set up their own competing
systems and who cares about the
ITS,
which is a dinosaur,
which nobody likes.
That's something we have to
recognize--that there are
different approaches and there
are going to be clever people
who come up with new ideas about
how to trade stocks.
This brings us to the so called
ECNs.
They were called electronic
communications networks and what
happened was with the advent of
the Internet--in the mid-1990s,
people started setting up
websites that looked like stock
exchanges, but maybe they
weren't.
I guess the first one was
Instinet--I'm not sure it's the
absolute first one,
but Instinet was--now,
understand that an exchange has
to register with the SEC.
The SEC has all kinds of
requirements,
and if you're setting up some
website, you probably can't
satisfy all those requirements.
So, Instinet set up an
electronic bulletin board,
I called it,
which was not an exchange but
it was a place where people
interested in buying and selling
shares could post their
interest.
It was like an electronic
bulletin board,
so it would be especially
important for people who are
placing really big orders
because they might want to not
just put it on the floor of the
exchange.
But to--they might want to say
something on the thing about
under what conditions I would
buy this or something like that.
It became more flexible and
became very popular among
institutional traders.
Then there was a number of
other--now the SEC allowed them
to function as ECNs,
which is a separate category,
and they started to look like
exchanges.
I guess the legal history of
these is very complicated.
They ended up merging with
exchanges;
this is in the 1990s and early
2000s.
I remember one that impressed
me because I had heard in the
'90s a talk from the founder;
Island was an exchange that was
created--can you see this?--that
was created for small investors.
It actually started to look a
lot like an exchange.
What I found interesting about
Island--the person I heard speak
about it in the '90s spoke of
this as democratizing
institutions.
It was the Web culture taking
over what the stock exchanges
had done.
What Island did was it posted
its limited, so called,
"order book" on the Web to the
whole world to see and it was
kind of challenging stock
exchanges,
which had kept the order books
more or less in secrecy.
Let me just step back and let's
go back to what happens on an
exchange and how Instinet and
Island are different.
There was another one--another
big one was called
Archipelago--that sounds like
Island.
It was another website that you
used to be able to get on and
you could read these order books
for any stock and you'd see
some--let's step back and talk
about what's goes on
traditionally at the New York
Stock Exchange and still goes on
today.
The New York Stock Exchange is
the biggest stock exchange in
the U.S., but also in some ways
the most-old fashioned.
They still have a floor,
a trading floor.
Most stock exchanges have
abolished their trading floor.
I just gave a talk in Moscow at
their stock exchange and I was
mentioning something about
trading floors and someone
raised his had in the audience
and says,
you're talking at the Russian
Stock Exchange trading floor;
that's where my talk was.
I didn't even know I was in it.
I was in the German Frankfurt
Stock Exchange and I was--they
said, I'll show you our trading
floor.
So, I walk in and I just see a
bunch of school children and
they had--there was nobody there
except school children.
It had turned into a museum.
That's what's happening all
over the world because
everything is going electronic.
The New York Stock Exchange,
and the Toronto Stock Exchange,
and the American Stock Exchange
are the few--or is it the
Montreal,
I forget now--anyway,
there are very few that still
do it this way.
[The Toronto Stock Exchange
replaced its trading floor with
an electronic system in
1997--the Montreal Exchange has
also augmented its trading with
its SOLA platform introduced in
2005.]
We still have a floor [at the
New York Stock Exchange].
So, you have,
for each stock,
you have a specialist who
stands at a post on the floor of
the exchange;
so each stock has a specialist.
Then you have traders who roam
around the floor and go
to--these are brokers or dealers
who are trying to buy and sell
stocks and they go to the
various posts and make their
rounds.
They have so many stocks they
want to buy and so many they
want to sell and they go around
on the floor of the exchange.
If they want to buy a
particular company,
they go to--they know where
that specialist is and they go
there.
On the floor of the exchange,
they can either buy and sell
from the specialist,
who is a dealer,
who maintains an inventory,
or they can buy and sell from
anybody else they meet at the
post.
Of course, everyone there is
licensed;
it's not open to the public.
What happens is,
there is a crowd that develops
at each specialist's post and
the crowd consists of people who
decided to go to that
specialist's post to look at
what they want to possibly buy
or sell.
They can buy or sell from
anyone.
The specialist is sometimes
just standing there watching and
it's all happening.
The specialist--and the New
York Stock Exchange
maintains--that the specialist
fulfills an important function,
which is to create an orderly
market;
so, the specialist has a
responsibility as well as an
opportunity.
The other people at the crowd
are just doing their own
business, but the specialist is
supposed to be obligated to
preserve a good market.
If for some reason the price is
dropping rapidly and the
specialist thinks something's
wrong,
the specialist is supposed to
come in and buy on his or her
own account;
that's an obligation.
There have been problems.
For example,
in 1987, when the stock market
dropped precipitously,
there were criticisms of the
specialists for not buying to
support the market.
But then, specialists said in
their own defense,
what could we do?
The market is crashing.
So, it's not clear that
specialists make a huge
difference, but that's the
presumed advantage.
Now it used to be--this is an
interesting historical
thing--that before the 1930s
there were two crowds on the
stock exchange.
There was the buy/sell crowd
and there was another part of
the floor--I can't find this in
my notes--where stocks would be
rented.
I had the dates here and I
don't remember.
I can't find it in my notes.
[Charles Jones and Owen Lamont
report in their study of the
loan crowd that data on their
trades was published in the
Wall Street Journal from
1919 to 1933.]
Well anyway,
shares are--it's called the
loan crowd.
There used to be a special part
of the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange where stocks
would be lent rather than sold.
There are two things you can do;
there are two kinds of trade.
You go to a real estate
broker--you can say,
I want to buy a house or you
can say, I want to rent a house.
The broker can do both of those
for you.
Same thing with stocks--you can
say, I want to buy a stock or
you can say, I want to rent a
stock.
Or you can go the other way--I
want to sell a stock and I'd
like to rent out my stock.
Why would anyone want to rent a
stock?
Well, that's called short sales.
They would rent a stock and
sell it.
It used to be that--of course,
if you're lending out a stock,
you might demand some
compensation for that.
They used to argue--there would
be a specialist crowd called
the--there would be a loan crowd
that would argue about the
rental cost,
which is an interest cost for
borrowing a security.
The Wall Street Journal
used to publish--there were two
stock sections;
there was the price section and
there was the loan section.
That, however,
disappeared after the stock
market crash of 1929.
Apparently, it disappeared
because of concern that shorting
stocks was the cause of the 1929
crash.
The story was that J.
Edgar Hoover,
who was head of the F.B.I.,
thought that shorting stocks
had caused the Crash and he
didn't like it.
If J.
Edgar Hoover didn't like what
you were doing back then,
you were afraid and worried.
So, the New York Stock
Exchange, without ever
publishing it,
just shut the whole thing down
and to this day,
we don't have a loan crowd
anymore.
We do still lend out shares,
but it's not done on the floor
of the exchange.
Anyway, the specialist at the
floor of the exchange has a book
and it used to be a big thick
paper book.
What the specialist would
do--the specialist would record
in the book offers and bids--bid
and asked prices.
There would be people who would
tell the specialist that I want
to sell so many shares at such a
price or buy so many shares at
such a price and the book would
show the list of orders that
were outstanding.
Now, this comes back to--I
should clarify kinds of orders.
When you call up a broker and
say, I would like to buy or sell
shares, there's different--you
can give--you're giving your
broker an order.
You can give the broker a
market order.
If you give a market order to
your broker, you're saying you
only have to give the broker one
number, which is a number of
shares.
So, I can have a buy order or a
sell order--market order.
If it's a buy order,
all I do is say,
I want you to buy for me,
let's say, 1,000 shares of this
company at whatever price is out
there;
just get the best price you
can, but execute it right now.
It only gives a number of
shares.
Another kind of order,
however, is a limit order.
With this order you have to
tell the broker both the number
of shares and the price.
There's either a buy or a sell,
so if it's a buy limit order,
you want to say,
I want you to buy the stock at
any price up to the one I
mentioned.
So, I would give--I would say,
1,000 shares at $30 a share and
that means that if it's a buy
order, you wait until--you don't
execute it immediately.
You execute it when the price
falls below $30.
A person would do this who
thinks, I think the stock is a
good buy at $30,
but not where it's trading now
at $35.
So, I just put--and just tell
my broker, I want you to take
this limit order and I don't
expect you to fill this order.
Maybe you'll never fill it,
but I just want it to be there
until I correct it.
You're just supposed to be
standing ready and you're
supposed to notice when the
price falls below $30 and then
you buy.
If it was a sell limit order
you would say,
I want you to sell it if the
price gets up to $40.
Again, if it's above the
current market price,
it won't be executed now;
it might never be executed.
Then there's another kind of
order called a stop-loss order.
With a stop-loss order,
like a limit order,
you have to both give a
quantity and a price to your
broker when you place the order.
It's similar to a--it's in a
different--a stop--a sell--you
could have the same numbers
here;
you could say 1,000 and $30
again, but it would have a
different meaning.
A stop-loss order says to sell
when the price hits $30.
In this case,
if it were a stop loss order
for 1,000 shares at $30 it would
be to sell--if the price today
is $35--not buy.
It's a different
motivation--that you would do a
stop-loss order.
You see the difference?
If it's a limit order,
I'm saying I think the stock is
only worth $30;
I want to buy it when it gets
down to $30.
With a stop-loss order,
if the actual price today is
$35 a share, I'm saying,
I'm worried about the stock
crashing on me,
so I want you to get me out if
it's crashing.
The broker has to know,
well when do I get you out?
Well, you have to say when,
so this is when.
So, you'd be telling,
if it's a sell order,
you would be telling your
broker, sell the stock if the
price falls below $30.
There's a fundamental
difference between a limit order
and a stop-loss order.
There's also a buy-stop order.
You could tell your broker,
I want you to buy the stock if
the price rises above $40.
Now, why would someone do that?
Why would you tell--have an
order to buy the stock only if
it gets expensive?
Well, the people who would do
that are people who have shorted
the stock.
If you've shorted the stock and
the stock price starts going up,
you're potentially in big
trouble.
So, if you worry about that,
then you can say a buy-stop
order and place that with your
broker.
What Island did--I'm going back
to--the brokers used to have all
these orders--well,
the market orders wouldn't end
up on their book because it
would just be executed
immediately and it would be
gone.
These limit orders and
stop-loss orders would be on the
book of the broker and the
broker would then know--the
specialist at the exchange would
have this book,
which recorded customers'
orders.
So, the specialist would
understand the market because it
would have a whole bunch of
these orders on the books.
The nice thing about Island,
when it became part of our Web
culture in the 1970s,
is they created their own book
on the Web, so you could
get--you could actually--it was
open to everyone.
You'd have the--you would have
buy orders and sell orders and
this would be something you
could see on the Web.
Actually, you can see things
like this on the Web now too,
but not through Island anymore.
Let's say this is some company,
let's say it's IBM,
and you would see something
like this.
It would be--the buy orders
would--it would be--the first
one would say for $90 a share,
100 shares.
Someone's willing to buy 100
shares at $90 and over here you
would see something like,
someone is willing to sell at
$92, let's say 200 shares.
There's no trade here, right?
If somebody is willing to buy
at 90 and someone else is
willing to buy at $92 there's no
trade.
Then you'll see other orders;
somebody else is willing to buy
at 89 1/2, say 200 shares,
and you see these descending.
I'm just making up numbers--$88
for 1,000 shares and so on.
On sell, we then see other
people, someone who's going at
92 1/4 for 300 shares.
I'm showing all the purchases
in round lots;
a round lot is 100 shares.
You could also have odd lots,
but most of the time people put
round lots on as a trade.
This book would then sit there;
there's no trade here.
This is the inside spread.
That is the--on the limit order
book, those are the trades that
are closest to execution,
but it's not an executable
trade yet.
What would happen then--and it
was as you would watch the
book--and since it's now
electronic, it corrects itself
quickly.
I don't know what the
specialist had to do with a
feather pen.
Originally, they would have to
cross these things out with ink
and the book was probably hard
to maintain, but now it's all
automatic.
Suppose someone comes in with a
buy order for 100 at 90 and a
sell order for 100 at 90,
so someone's willing to sell at
a lower price.
What happens immediately on
this--this thing becomes
executed and disappears,
so you see that happening on
the book.
It's fun to watch an electronic
book.
This is what brokers see who
are members of NASDAQ and they
see the electronic trading
system.
Of course, there are many such
books now that are available.
The dealer--the specialist on
the exchange also has his
own--his or her own--bid-asked
spread, which is also an offer
to buy or sell on the exchange.
Incidentally,
Island would only allow one
kind of order,
at least originally.
It was only limit orders
because they didn't--they had a
system where you had to put it
onto their book and everything
had to appear on the book,
so it was just a limit order
book originally.
The history of this--I guess
one thing I wanted to--what I
was leading up to is that the
ECNs are history now.
They've been generally merged
and acquired.
Notably, the New York Stock
Exchange, which has been the
holdout doing floor trading,
bought Archipelago because
Archipelago was growing so fast
doing this kind of electronic
trading;
it was really catching on.
New York Stock Exchange began
to worry that it was starting to
get behind the times.
The New York Stock--these
things, which were started by
kids--young college students in
the late ‘90s--just grew
so fast and they got so big that
Archipelago was starting to look
like it was going to get bigger
than New York Stock Exchange.
So, finally New York Stock
Exchange merged with them and
they changed the name after 200
years in business.
They changed the name to NYSE
Archa--Archa is short for
Archipelago Exchange.
That didn't last long;
they changed their name again.
They just merged--New York
Stock Exchange merged with the
European Stock Exchange,
Euronext, and so now it's
called NYSE Euronext.
Everything happened so fast and
it seems fast to me.
The New York Stock Exchange is
in the process,
we think, of merging with the
American Stock Exchange and
that's happening right now.
[NYSE Euronext announced on
January 17,2008 a "definitive
agreement" to acquire the AMEX.]
I wanted to just finish with
just a little bit of a thought
about what it means to be a
dealer in this market.
What is it that if you are a
dealer operating on one of these
exchanges, you are placing
orders,
effectively,
in somebody's book and standing
ready to buy or sell.
A dealer is someone who is
trading everyday,
who has an inventory of stocks
for trading.
I want to just maybe close with
a little thought about what it's
like to be a dealer.
I've never been a dealer and I
don't know the emotional thing,
but the problem with being a
dealer of any kind--maybe it
takes a certain moral stamina,
mental stamina,
to do this kind of thing--is
that you're trading everyday.
You're not someone who's
managing the Yale portfolio.
What you're trying to do is
make money everyday by buying
low and selling high and you
have to be ready to stand--ready
to take orders--because people
come to you.
Someone will come to you or
there will be someone in a
specialist's crowd who wants to
place an order or buy or sell
and you have an inventory.
You're like an antiques dealer
and one problem is that your
life's work, unfortunately,
as a dealer is summarized by
your portfolio and your
inventory.
That's why I didn't become a
dealer, actually.
I don't--I guess you have to
have the right stomach of steel
or something.
The thing that I wanted to
impress on you is that no matter
how well you do,
your cumulative score is there
in your portfolio and it's a
competitive business.
So, you run the risk of being
ruined at any time in your life.
This just--I want to remind you
of what's called the gambler's
ruin problem because being a
dealer is a little bit like
being someone who goes to the
gambling casino everyday.
If you enjoy your visit to the
gambling casino,
maybe you want to be a dealer.
Actually, I don't really enjoy
it, so I'm just not the right
person to do this.
What I really wouldn't like
about it is that you always
stand the chance of being
ruined--that is,
losing everything.
So, I just want to review.
This is a little bit of
mathematics that is in market
microstructure theory.
Suppose you're a dealer and you
have a way of either winning or
losing money on each
transaction.
Suppose the probability of
winning on a transaction is
equal to p--that's the
probability of winning on one of
your trades.
To simplify this thing,
let's say that you either win
or lose.
If you win, you get $1;
if you lose, you lose $1.
So, you win $1 with probability
p and you lose $1 with
probability 1 - p.
I want to know,
what is your life career going
to look like if you're just
doing this everyday for the next
thirty years?
Well, the first question is,
what is the probability of your
being ruined?
Let's start with the case
p = ½
and let's not say--thirty years
is close enough to infinity,
but let's just say you're going
to do this forever because I
don't want to have to figure out
the effect of the last day.
What do you think is the
probability of being--remember,
being ruined means having your
inventory fall to zero.
You start with S
dollars--that's capital S
dollars--which is an integer.
When S falls to zero,
you are "ruined;"
you don't have any money left;
you're out of the game;
and you will be dismissed from
the exchange.
If you can't trade anymore,
you don't have anything.
You have to start with
something, otherwise you can't
trade at all.
So, S is something like
$100.
If p as a point--do any
of you know the answer?
What's the probability that I
will eventually be ruined?
This isn't something that you
got in your probability theory?
You got it right--that's right,
it's 100%.
You will with certainty be
ruined.
In fact, the probability of
ruin is ((1 -
p)/p)^S,
if p is greater than .5
or greater than-equal to .5.
That's because,
if you substitute in .5,
this is 1, so,
the probability of ruin is 1.
If it's--if the probability is
greater than .5,
then the probability of ruin
will be something less than 1.
This is actually easy to derive
because--think of it this
way--we'll call this the
probability of ruin,
if you have S dollars.
The reason it has this is
because if I start with s
dollars, there are two
possibilities:
either gain $1 or lose $1.
So, this probability of
S has to equal p x
Pr(S + 1) + (1 - p )
x Pr(S –
1).
That is the probability--this
is the probability of ruin if
you have S + $1 and this
you have S - $1.
So, the function determining
probability of S has to
satisfy this equation.
Also, we have the
restraint--the probability of
ruin if you have zero dollars is
1, so this is a difference
equation.
If you solve it, you get this.
What it means is that you had
better have a probability of
winning substantially above $1
or else have an awful lot of
dollars to start with.
Unfortunately,
it's hard to get the
probability of winning in any
one trade much up above ½
because you're living in a
competitive marketplace.
So, if p is close to
½, it's just a little bit
above ½,
then you will be standing for
your whole life,
always with a probability that
the rest of my life is going to
end up in ruin.
So, you may have been very
successful and you now have
S = 1000,
but the probability keeps going
down, but it never hits zero.
Student: A gambler can
take money off the table.
Professor Robert
Shiller: Well,
that's what you have--that's
what people do.
Student: I think you're
saying that the specialist--the
first few [inaudible].
Professor Robert
Shiller: Well,
they are taking money off
the--maybe because they are
doing that.
You live your life and you take
money off.
Yeah, you're right;
I don't have to play it out to
the bitter end like this.
I wanted to show--this is
actually--this mathematical
model is something that you will
find in the Page 1 or Chapter 1
of a market microstructure
textbook because you're right;
there are strategies that can
prevent ruin like that.
This is the basic--this is
just--I'm presenting this as a
very simple model of what
underlies the restriction on a
broker.
A broker has to
maintain--create a strategy such
that this p is
sufficiently probable--that this
ruin problem doesn't become
catastrophic.
The way they do that,
they set the bid-asked spread
that a dealer has with
consideration of this ruin
problem,
which has to be the focal point
of their attention.
They have to set the bid-asked
spread wide enough so that they
feel comfortable enough with
this probability of ruin.
If you don't--of course,
it's a competitive market and
so you can't get this
probability up too high.
So, if you don't like this,
don't become a dealer;
that's the way it is.
The people who are in this
business are people who can
tolerate this prospect of ruin.
On the other hand,
ruin isn't death;
that's another thing you were
saying.
I can make a living doing this
for a while and I am taking
money out and that's part of the
strategy.
Maybe I'm just being too much
of an academic here.
I live in great comfort in
academia and these beautiful
surroundings.
This university has been around
for 300 years;
I have no worries.
So, you might want to consider
an academic career instead of a
career in finance.
I hope to see you again then on
Friday.
I think we'll have a good time
with Schwarzman.